[MUSIC PLAYING]
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: Hello again.
I'm Dustin Kirkland.
And I'm here with
Maya Kaczorowski.
She is the security
product manager
for Containers at Google.
MAYA KACZOROWSKI: That's right.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: And
we're going to talk
a bit about the security
angle here at KubeCon.
And I think she's got a
pretty exciting announcement
from earlier today.
MAYA KACZOROWSKI: Yeah.
That's right.
So Google Community's Engine
information about clusters
are now included in the Cloud
Security Command Center.
The Cloud Security
Command Center
is our single pane of
glass for figuring out
what's happening
in your projects
from a security point of view.
Think about it as
security monitoring,
rather than, say,
application monitoring.
And now you can see what's
happening for those GKE
clusters right in cloud CSCC.
What's really
exciting about that
also is that we have five
container security partner
integrations natively in GKE in
Cloud Security Command Center.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: Can
you name all five?
MAYA KACZOROWSKI: Yes.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: OK.
MAYA KACZOROWSKI: Aqua Security,
Capsule 8, Stack Rocks,
Cystic Secure,
and Twist Lock all
can now write their
findings directly
to the Cloud Security
Command Center
for what you're running in GKE.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: Now,
is that run time?
Or is that at build
or developer time?
MAYA KACZOROWSKI: Sure.
So we think about
container security
at Google in three
different aspects.
One is what we'll call making
sure your containers are
secure to develop.
So do I have some way of
managing my network policies,
and secrets, and different
kinds of deployment policies,
identities, et cetera
that I'm going to have.
The second area is what
we'll call build and deploy
securities.
So how do you know that your
images are vulnerability-free,
don't contain
0-days, that they've
gone through your CICD
pipeline before they
deploy to production.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: Right.
MAYA KACZOROWSKI: The main
thing that we have in that space
right now is something
called Grafeas.
It's an open source project.
There's a couple talks,
actually, at KubeCon on Grafeas
by the TL of that
project, Wendy.
And that allows you to track
the metadata of your projects,
including vulnerability scan
results for those images
so you can then
determine whether or not
you can deploy those images.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND:
Kubernetes at large,
it seems like there's
a lot of work that's
gone into more secure
images without zero days.
It seems like something
that we've really
got to get on top of, right?
MAYA KACZOROWSKI:
It's certainly an area
with a lot of low-hanging fruit.
And there's a lot of
customer and partner
interest in that space.
The main problem to
solve in that space right
now is just the sheer
volume of vulnerabilities
that people have.
So I've had customers
ask me, what
do I do if I find a
vulnerability that doesn't
have a patch that exists yet?
And the reality
is, you're probably
thinking too far ahead.
You probably have a
ton of vulnerabilities
that are completely unpatched.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: Right.
MAYA KACZOROWSKI:
Fix those first
before you start to worry about
things that are unpatchable.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: So
is the best advice
we have to give is rely on
the operating systems vendors
to provide those updates,
and just make sure
that those updates are as
installed as possible in all
of your base images?
MAYA KACZOROWSKI:
So you're thinking
of actually a different layer
than what I'm thinking of.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: OK.
MAYA KACZOROWSKI: So you
can talk about the node OS
and the container OS.
And Google uses
container optimized OS
as the node OS, which
was open source.
It's based on Chromium OS.
And we have a great
blog post as to why
we think that's built
in a really secure way.
And then you can use
the container OS.
And we have lots of
options, again, on Google.
Or you can bring your own.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: Right.
MAYA KACZOROWSKI: And then
we have the image itself
that you're deploying.
And that might itself
have vulnerabilities.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: Right.
MAYA KACZOROWSKI: So if you're
running NGINX, or WordPress,
and that's a two-year-old
image, maybe you want to patch
that before you deploy.
Maybe you want to check
the age of your images.
Maybe you want to run some
standard scans, et cetera,
before you deploy that.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND:
And which of those
is the user's
responsibility, versus Google
takes care of on your behalf?
MAYA KACZOROWSKI: Sure.
If you're using a node
OS or a container OS,
it's provided by Google.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: OK.
MAYA KACZOROWSKI: It's Google's
responsibly to patch it.
But it's your responsibility
to pick what you want.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: OK.
So the user picks.
MAYA KACZOROWSKI: Correct.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: And
then Google handles
the patching of the base OS as
a managed service effectively.
MAYA KACZOROWSKI: If they
pick an OS that we provide.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: OK.
MAYA KACZOROWSKI:
So if you choose
to bring your own
container OS, then it's
your responsibility, obviously.
The image itself is your
responsibility to secure.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: OK.
But this single
pane of glass now
should maybe help
users a bit more?
MAYA KACZOROWSKI: Ah.
So that's the third area.
So that's our container
runtime security
area, which is, I have
a container now running
in production.
And I've done everything
I can to fiddle
with all the things in GKE, and
scan my images before they're
deployed.
But what if there
still is an 0-day,
and what if somebody
gets into my container
and starts doing something bad?
How do I detect that,
react, do forensics
after the fact, et cetera?
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: Yeah.
MAYA KACZOROWSKI: And that's
container runtime security.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: OK.
MAYA KACZOROWSKI: And
that's a super nascent
space, an area we realize
there's a lot of interest in.
Hence, the integrations of
five partners with the Cloud
Security Command Center.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: Right.
And are any of these
helping us with forensics?
I'm guessing that's
snapshotting the container,
knowing what it looked like
at various points in time,
maybe being able to roll
back debug logs or monitoring
logs, and--
I don't know-- trace the
origination of the attack?
MAYA KACZOROWSKI: That's a
still fairly new capability.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: OK.
Wishful thinking, right?
MAYA KACZOROWSKI: Yeah.
A lot of the partners
have tooling around
a longer set of logs.
So you might have logs that
are written temporarily,
to like a ring
buffer, for example.
And then once you
detect an incident,
you flag those logs and
start writing those.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: Right.
MAYA KACZOROWSKI: It's
not necessarily full image
snapshotting that's
happening yet.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: Right.
That's where we're at today.
So we covered the
three different areas.
I'm curious if there
are kinds of attacks
that you'd like to
maybe highlight?
The types of things
that either developers
should be aware of when
writing an application,
or IT administrators
should be aware
of as their operating clusters?
MAYA KACZOROWSKI: Yeah.
I mean, it's, in
some sense, it's kind
of boring for a
security professional.
It's not that different than
what you see as attacking a VM,
right?
You're going to see credential
theft, privilege escalation.
You might see abuse of compute.
In this case, crypto mining's
a fairly popular thing to do.
They're not new
kinds of attacks.
And often people
are actually not
aware that they're
in a container
when they're
[INAUDIBLE] attacks.
They're not attacking
Kubernetes per se.
They're just attacking
some open compute thing.
And oh, I happen to
be in a container.
That's great.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: Indeed.
Interesting.
So different question.
Moving away from
security a little bit.
Just looking at the community,
the at large community
around Kubernetes,
are there maybe
any people, individuals in
the community that you'd
like to recognize as someone
who inspires you, has maybe
helped you out, or
helped out the project
in the last few months?
MAYA KACZOROWSKI: Yeah.
I think we're really
fortunate in security.
Everyone who's involved
in [? CIGOFF ?]
is really a stellar,
stellar individual.
I'd like to call out Eric Chang
from Red Hat, [INAUDIBLE]..
He's been really great at doing
a lot of the IEM [? R-back ?]
type work in Kubernetes.
If you want a good description
of [? R-back, ?] go talk
to Eric.
He will explain it to you.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: I was
just about to ask you.
MAYA KACZOROWSKI: 30
seconds or an hour long,
depending on what you like, and
what he does or doesn't like
about [? R-back. ?]
Eric's also been leading a
lot of the thought leadership
in [? CIGOFF. ?] So he's
been really great to have
to have him involved.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: Yeah.
That's great.
Then finding, finally,
one last question.
Can you tell us-- people
are super interested-- how
you got into Kubernetes?
What was your introduction
to Kubernetes?
MAYA KACZOROWSKI: People are not
super interested in this stuff.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: No.
They're very, very interested.
MAYA KACZOROWSKI: I'm a
very pragmatic person.
I worked in security
for a while.
And I wanted to
work on something
that I thought was going to
10X in the next five years.
Containers are going to
There will be security problems.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: There you go.
MAYA KACZOROWSKI: And
also job security.
And ideally, we can prevent
those security problems
before they happen.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: All right.
Well, good.
Well, thank you very much.
MAYA KACZOROWSKI: Thank you.